make me say
breaking news man-sized homunculus plays
with superhero toys
[Music]
and after the break unicorns are real
and boy are they hot
[Music]
this just in a new study shows twerking
helps lower cholesterol
this just in i've decided not to remove
my [ __ ] stamp
this just in mercenary wade wilson is
still being held captive by a deranged
kidnapper
[Music]
just in bob makes a reservation for one
at the mall food court
hey can i get a double patty uh
wolverine style
uh is that gluten free
gluten makes me gassy
garcon if this isn't as hot as sun spots
meatballs i'm sending it straight back
to the kitchen
hey bud can you read me the specials in
your best wolverine voice
i need it extra spicy like my holster is
a volcano spicy
i'll take the gluten-free steak tips
with a
side of vegan broccoli
and
is your almond milk free range
ooh
ugh you smell like beast lab after taco
night
selfie
ugh you smell like an expired carton of
eggnog had a secondary mutation
you're so ugly you caused a mutant
massacre
serious tragedy
uncanny
210
our heroes will never be the same
whoa that's an ugg mug
oh you've got such a nice smile it's
almost like you had a happy childhood
you are super attractive
you can't tell but i'm using air quotes
you smell like beast lab after taco
night
selfie
selfie
you gotta oppose me i don't have a booty
okay let's get one for grandma
okay let's get one for grandma mom
you think just because i don't have a
body i can't kick your
well
let's dance
listen dumb crunch i may have lost my
body in a freak car wash accident but i
still have teeth
hey bub i'm the second best at doing
what wolvy does so like don't mess with
the head brah
i'm here to chew gum and chew gum
do you have any gum
you talking to me
are you talking to me
oh you are talking to me hi
name's paul
deadpool
nice to meet you
wow
hi there
my name is wade but you can call me
[Music]
ronaldo
greetings from your astonishing uncanny
pool guy
oh hello
i'm the grossly underpaid voice of
deadpool's head
hi
hi i'm wade but you can call me the nail
in the coffin of your marriage
bye bye
i like my x-men with big guns and full
pouches
wolverine's actually just a giant
talking wolverine
truth is i lost my body trying to
teleport with my crawler into a taxi
truth is i lost my body playing double
dutch with some banffs
look i'm not saying that beast has lice
but beast definitely has fleas
i mean let's face it cable you gotta
update your name buddy it's the 21st
century
how about
captain streaming
i've got to go gotta take sabertooth for
a walk
peace out you mother father yup that's
how we swear on basic cable
bye bye
see you after your 10 years stint in the
vault
tell juggernut i said hi
i gotta go
baby seal in the oven
bye bye
gotta go
big comic book crossover in progress and
you weren't invited
you
holy
censor
censored again
pg-13
jimmy
shape-shifters y'all a bunch of
shape-shifters
morph
k-pop is not for sissies
good night body
wherever you are
i've been watching you at night
i think you have sleep apnea
juggernaut smash beauty stump pool
[Music]
oh logan
you're the best there is at what you do
oh look
i love it when you call me bob
how about we make our way down to the
danger room give that all new all
different thing a whirl
wolverine's actually just a giant
talking wolverine
and after the break unicorns are real
and boy are they hot
what do we do with pranking somebody
nice i'm ready when you are
ooh
okay leave me on top of the toilet like
the stinking upper decker i am
prank activated
not gonna know what hit him
hey occupied
whoa whoa whoa ocupado
i gotta pee
oh nevermind
phantom bladder
okay put me on the bed and turn off the
lights i'm willing to bet you don't hear
that often
frank activated
not gonna know what hit him
oh
ah
marina the submariner sleeps with the
fishes
sup
come here
oh do you want me to make some relaxing
ocean noises
relax relax relax
okay put me in the fridge and shut the
door
prank activated
and away we go
something in here went bad i swear it
wasn't me
hey there's more heads in the freezer
what's in the toy box oh what's in the
toy box
pranktivation complete
they said it was going to be 911
[Applause]
oh
welcome to my prank bank
did you bring both keys
welcome to pranktown population
me
you're straight i totally high-five you
but you know
no hands
huh so how does it feel to talk to
someone irl
excuse me you want to know how i lost my
body
tiger shark bitted clean off i was
saving ronaldo from a body surfing
accident
party mode initiated let's make some
quote-unquote friends
that is so raven dark home
[Music]
hey
whoops
oh
moist
oh
i like the way you think let's take this
party to the next level
oh wow
please help me get out of here
night time
hot
i know it's a politically unpopular
opinion but
duke was right
[Applause]
putting on my therapist half for a
second where do you see yourself in uh
say 115 years
earth to bob anybody home
never mind
okay
let's see what else this app can do
oh yeah you really push my buttons
danger room sequence activated
difficulty level
more lock ah come on
oh yeah push it two more times
fast
fart button
whoa you just launched the warhead at
canada
hashtag awkward
absolutely do not press that button
again
wow
you found my time travel button tap
1602 times for 1602
wow
you found my time travel button tap 2099
times for the year 2099.
wow
you found my time travel button tap
1602 times for 16.02
[Music]
got it i'll set your alarm for 4 20 am
dude
hey can i get a double paddy uh
wolverine style
garson
if this isn't as hot as sun spots
meatballs i'm sending it straight back
to the kitchen
yeah
deck ride
oh
i want you to draw me like one of your
french mutants gambit or maybe phantom x
[Applause]